[Music]
well you've done all your planning you
know what where you can build a dam you
know how big a dam you want
you know you're sitting within
legislation uh you're right to go
there's three probably different types
of dams or construction you look at so
you've got a one wall or a single wall
two wall or a three wall we're looking
at here today
your landscape will determine what type
of dam you need and your your operator
or your designer will understand exactly
what is needed for that situation
everything you do when you're
constructing a gym is about longevity
good planning when you're pegging your
dam is is very vital and to consider
where your outlet's going to be and
where your trigger pipe's going to spill
the outlet is where the water leaves
your dam so that outlet needs to match
the amount of water that's coming in
your dam so when you've got a storm the
water needs to be able to exit the dam
as much as it's coming into the dam so
they need to match each other
you want to see a good outlet you want
to make sure that outlet is outletting
free of the dam it's not running beside
a damn bank and causing damage to your
dam it's not causing erosion so you need
your spill area to go into nice grass
flat area
other considerations are do you need a
trickle pipe is it a trick or flow to
have that trickle pipe in your dam will
keep your outlet dry and it will keep
your paddock dry where that water's
leaving your dam so that trickle pipe
will
exit that small flow straight behind
your dam into the existing area of where
it would have naturally went
a bad outlet you'll see your damn outlet
will start to erode you'll start to get
channelizing of your outlet and your dam
is basically starting to break down or
deteriorating so a good outlet is vital
a key point when you're building a dam
is you want to make sure that all your
water is covering your excavation so
whenever you're excavating material to
build your dam water's got to cover that
if that's exposed and water can run over
it when it's filling that's a potential
point to start erosion
you want to make sure you've got good
clay coming up over your banks
you want to make sure they put a key in
so when you strip all your topsoil off
you take that to the back of your dam
and then you build your dam out of good
clay you want to make sure where the
clay is touching the ground they've put
what they call a key line in so it's
actually clay laying on clay
and when you're finished you bring that
topsoil back up over your dam and so
your dam can be grassed up in the future
if you've got a really good operator
they'll understand that you need good
compaction of your soil so when they're
building it they need to be compacting
that clay material as they build it
that's a determination of whether a dam
can fail
whether it'll leak
so in this example we've got a really
good well constructed dam this dam's
probably 10 to 12 years old and you can
see it's still in really good nick
you've got a good batter on the back and
a good batter on the front
you want to be seeing a three to one on
the front and minimum two and a half to
three to one on the back side of the dam
you'll have a crest so the width of the
top of the bank you want to be looking
at a good three metre so you're after a
big fat bank
the other consideration is what we call
freeboard so that's the amount of
material above top watermark to the top
of the bank you're looking at a minimum
of a meter free board and if you've got
all them aspects you're going to have a
well constructed dam
as you can see if you can get your dam
construction right you'll have a good
reliable dam into the future
[Music]